the cdc plans to unveil long-awaited
guidelines today for reopening
k-12 schools and we have details first
from a draft internal summary
obtained by cbs news nancy cordes is at
the white house nancy what do these
proposed guidelines
say exactly well anthony good morning
from
a very festive valentine's day
decked out white house so according to
the guidelines that cbs news
has viewed schools would fall into four
color-coded categories they would reopen
with full in-person learning in the
schools with low community spread those
would be the blue
and yellow zones as long as there was as
much social distancing as possible those
schools could
reopen schools in the orange zone where
transmission rates are higher
would be recommended for hybrid or
reduced attendance
with required distancing now this same
guidance goes for schools in the
red zone if they regularly test staff
and students
for red zone schools that don't
regularly test the cdc would recommend
elementary schools have reduced
attendance with mandatory distancing
and virtual only classes for middle and
high schools
now these guided lines are also expected
to include mitigation strategies like
masks and
hand washing resources devoted to
under-resourced communities
prioritizing teachers for vaccines and
accommodating
high risk educators with virtual
teaching
or flexible schedules now officials tell
cbs news that these guidelines are still
being finalized and
could change and what we still don't
know is what rates of community spread
apply to each of these zones we're
hoping to get more details
later today nancy as we heard president
biden says
he now has secured enough doses
to vaccinate nearly the whole country
that's right he
says that his government has arranged
for 200 million
more doses of the vaccine and so it will
have enough vaccine
for 300 million americans he says by the
end of july
the president acknowledged the
logistical challenges in distributing
these vaccines blaming that in part
on the previous administration while
scientists did their job in discovering
vaccines in record time my predecessor
be very blunt about it did not do his
job in getting ready for the massive
challenge of vaccinating
hundreds of millions of americans we
started on day one
we won't have everything fixed for a
while
but we're going to fix it
later today the president is going to
meet with governors and mayors to talk
with them about pandemic relief many of
them have been very
vocal about how frustrated they are that
the vaccine
keeps running out after that the
president is expected to head to camp
david
for the weekend tony i'll take it nancy
encouraging news on the vaccine front
and glad the white house is out in front
on valentine's day thanks
nancy what does it say behind you what
are the signs what are the hearts you
thank you very much